so last session of the boot camp and me
what's gonna okay so I'm going to go on
till 3:30 and then you'll have another
break okay so like I said the main thing
I want to I want to prove now is that if
you have a if you have a mate right then
it's polynomial is going to satisfy this
complete la concavity whose definition I
gave you so it turns out that the first
time that we the first time that we
encountered this and we empirically
observed it we looked around for for
tools to basically use to prove it it
turns out there is this beautiful Theory
Hodge theory which I which I mentioned
in the beginning of the talk and you can
use that theory to to prove the
statement but today I want to give you a
different proof so but before I going to
to this different proof let me let me
say that now we have found that this
this definition is equivalent to a lot
of other definitions that different
groups have found out so so strong law
concavity is the thing that that curve
it's used to derive inequalities on the
coefficients of faults so yeah so strong
a concavity like I said is the is the
simpler thing where you replace
directional derivatives by partial
derivatives so now we know that these
two are basically equivalent at least
for homogeneous polynomials
so so whenever you have a shadow of a
Haj theory there are inequalities in
[ __ ] which I might get to which which
give you a power mule so so as long as
you have these so-called hajiman
inequalities in some algebra you
magically get a polynomial which turns
out to be la concave and from any
polynomial that's la concave you can
also construct an algebra where you have
these inequalities I might get to this
and if I have time so it also turns out
to be equivalent to a notion of high
dimensional expansion won't get to that
in this talk but you'll see that later
on in the semester and there is also an
independent notion developed by header
and junior and I'll mention what this
notion is but it's basically equivalent
to complete la concavity so so okay so
complete la concavity I've written again
the definition here you start from a
polynomial you take directional
derivatives along positive directions
and you want the end result to be LA
concave right so as I mentioned
derivatives along all possible
directions is not really necessary you
can only take directions along the the
standard basis and as long as the end
result is LA concave you have this
entire complete la concavity so this is
a this is a statement that we showed
that if you have a palm you'll a as long
as it satisfies some non degeneracy
assumptions which I'll mention it's
enough to only check this property when
the number of derivatives you're taking
is the degree of your palm y -2 so the
end result is a degree 2 polynomial and
as long as the directions are along
their standard basis so you're taking
real partial derivatives you need to
connect you
you need the connectivity I think is
that one of the reason I need that thing
is to fight with the Kinect to
complement the situation the problem
which I was interested was to check with
the polynomial can be factorized into
problem yeah exactly that's to prevent
that if you need yeah you need some
something like this I'll mention what it
is and then okay so once you get so so
this is just for simplicity over D
homogeneous polynomials you can you can
reduce everything to D homogeneity so
once you get to a degree two polynomial
the thing that you have to check for la
concavity is that the Hessian of the
degree to pommel this is like a constant
matrix right doesn't matter which point
you evaluate that this thing has at most
one positive eigen value so this notion
that I that Peter and Julie Haas
developed is basically the premise of
these two theorems okay so you call upon
your belonging to to this class if it
satisfies the premise of these two
theorems and of course the now the hard
thing becomes proving that certain
operations preserve this property the
second one is easy
yeah yeah second one is very easy okay
so let me give you two examples of this
so so we are going to see what this
means for bivariate homogeneous
polynomials and form a trade pals so if
you have a bivariate homogeneous phone
you know you can always it's associated
to basically a sequence because if you
have G of Z 1 and Z 2 or let me G of x
and y
it's always of this form a 0 X to the D
Y to the 0 plus and 1 X to the D minus 1
Y to the 1 up to a D X to the 0 Y to the
D okay so once you take a bunch of
partial derivatives of such a thing
until you get to a degree 2 formula that
degree 2 polynomial is going to have
three consecutive terms of this okay
and it's Hessian is going to be of this
form so the Hessian of basically partial
X to the a partial y to the D minus K
minus 2 G this is going to end up being
a 2 by 2 matrix which is of this form so
you get a to the a of
- K&Y to the K minus 2 okay so you get a
of K minus 2 divided by D choose K minus
2 K of K divided by D choose K K of K
minus 1 divided by you choose K minus 1
and a FK minus 1 divided by D choose K
minus 1 and the whole thing multiplied
by D factorial so so in the in the in
the binomial coefficients that you see
there are basically two kinds of
factorials there is a D factorial which
basically cancels out with this global D
factorial the other factorial is coming
from taking derivatives of x and y so
you end up getting to this sort of a
polynomial right to this sort of a
matrix now this matrix has positive
entries right so it's Trace is positive
so it's gonna have either two positive
eigenvalues or one positive eigenvalue
one negative eigenvalue and the way you
can determine which is the case is by
computing the design of the determinant
okay so having one positive at most one
positive eigenvalue is basically
equivalent to the determinant of this
being negative which means that a k
divided or a k minus 2 divided by b
choose K minus 2 times a K divided by P
choose K is less than a K minus 1
divided by D choose K minus 1 the whole
thing squared
so we've already seen this property this
is exactly the same as the Newton
inequalities right or ultra low
concavity okay so now let me let me
mention what this connected being
connected support means okay this is a
good place to do this rate it so if you
have a sequence which satisfies these
local conditions right it's not so so
when people are talking about La concave
sequences what they usually mean is La
concave sequences with no internal zeros
okay
so if you have let's say two to two
sequences which are which are La concave
or altar la concave and let's say this
one goes up to a K and the other one
starts from like
so if you have a sequence of this form
which has internal zeros okay so it can
still satisfy inequalities of this form
but you're not generally considering
this law concave because because really
it's composed of two separate LA concave
sequences one is the the first one
before the first zero and the other one
is the one after the second zero okay
what's happening is that inequalities of
this form becomes sort of degenerate at
these points so so that so being
connected support is exactly to prevent
things of this form okay so if you have
if you have a sequence where the local
the local constraints are satisfied and
you formed by the corresponding by
varying form you know it's not going to
be LA concave it's not going to be
completely LA concave if it has internal
zeros so being being connected support
is a condition that prevents things of
this form and for multivariate
polynomials what that means is so we
call G mu
connected support if whenever you take a
bunch of partial derivatives so partial
derivative along Y I won the I to of to
e IJ
the sequence cannot satisfy me why not
because it's supposed to be concave not
necessarily if you concave my neighbors
this concave is right no no I mean so so
let's say you have this sequence right
so you have 1 0 0 0 1 right which one of
the inequalities is because 0 supposed
to be greater amico any guy in the
middle supposed to be great where is
that inequality failing in the sequence
you see it's not a local condition
no but you I think you know you can't
combine local condition to prove zeros
are they think so so when you are when
you are basically combining the local
conditions to get the global conditions
that you're talking about then you have
zeros you are dividing by zeros and
things get messed up so you can just
check that for these sequence you have
any qualities of this form always right
but it's not connected support yes I put
two consecutive zeros here
so okay so the condition that you you
really need is this that when you take
partial derivatives of your function
this time I'm not going to take partial
derivatives until I get to a degree 2
ponyo I stop this somewhere before
somewhere before I get to a degree 2
polynomial then the polymer cannot be
decomposed into a sum of basically H 1
and H 2 where H 1 is on a set of
variables H 2 is on the complements of
that that's it right so H 1 is on are
basically the I sign s and H 2 is in are
of the eyes I not eNOS you want this to
never happen okay so so why does that
prevent internal zeros from happening in
this case if you have internal zeros by
taking derivatives you can basically
zoom in on this window right the the
last guy which is nonzero here
the first guy which is nonzero here and
you can just kill off the other terms
right now now this thing is going to be
something of this form a K X to some
power but Y to the 0 plus a k plus 3
there might be some coefficients here to
some factor you'll see a 2 X to the 0 Y
to some other power right this is
written already as a sum of two
polynomials one on X 1 on Y right
so you so having having that condition
prevents internal zeros from happening
in the bivariate case and that's that's
the sort of thing that you need in the
general case do exactly that condition
that I've written
all right so now before we again go to
the break let me just do the metroid
case and finally prove that matrix
satisfy the promise of this or the
premise of these theorems
so so the cool thing that happens for
Metroid's is that micro polynomials are
closed under taking partial derivatives
okay so if you start from some a troy m
and you look at g of m when you take the
partial derivative with respect to that
say zi this is the same as the matrix
power meal for M contracted with I this
is the sine of contraction no okay sorry
okay so so when you take the partial
derivative with respect to Z I you are
basically throwing away all bases that
don't contain the I and then from the
bases that contains the I you're just
throwing out I right so may try power
matrix polynomials are closed under the
operation of taking partial derivatives
and then you can also check that they
can never be decomposed so they also
satisfy this connected support condition
so all it boils down yeah so yeah
basically if you if you connect spaces
of matrix when if you connect basically
basis of matrix by connect basis of
Metroid's that connect two bases
whenever they differ in only two
elements this graph becomes connected
this is that so okay so all it boils
down to is to prove the right hand side
for for for Metroid's but on the right
hand side you are talking only about
degree two polynomial right so the
metroid must be a rank two metroid so
rank to meit roids we know them all and
we know exactly what they look like so
here is a here is a picture of a rank
two metroid so let's say that the
metroid is on elements 1 2 up to n
because i'm rank two I can represent
bases using edges between the nodes
right whenever there is a base
containing two elements I just connect
them
so you can basically verify that using
the Metroid axioms the graph that you're
going to get here is a complete
multi-part I'd graph so there is a way
to partition the elements in two sets so
that whenever you pick two vertices from
different sets you have an edge and
whenever you pick two where this is from
the same set you don't have an edge
between them these are exactly all
matrix of rank two so so then for for a
matrix of rank two now you can exactly
write down the polynomial the
corresponding polynomial it's going to
be of this form
it's going to be 1/2 z1 up to the N
times a matrix which is basically the
adjacency matrix of that graph zeroes on
blocks on the diagonal and ones
everywhere else I have Z 1 up to the end
just see that this is exactly the
generating column you love the mate
right so I have to verify that the
Hessian of this thing has at most one
positive eigenvalue but of course the
Hessian I've already written it down for
you it's exactly this matrix so why does
this matrix have at most one positive
eigen value so you can just observe that
this matrix is basically the all one's
matrix minus something which has ones on
the blocks on the diagonal and zeros
everywhere else so so the palm you or
the matrix that you start with is a rank
one matrix and then you subtract
something which is PSD from it so the so
when you start with this matrix you have
one positive eigenvalue and this can
only take the argument out okay so in
the end you're gonna end up with
something which has at most one positive
eigenvalue
all right so I think we should take a
break so by the way it's a simple stuff
but it was in my pre-approval for matrix
oh okay I didn't know so actually they
they not give gives those blocks those
parts have the same cardinality there is
a very simple proof based on tensor
product so if they have the same
cardinality you get J minus I tensor
something okay
so I think we should take a break
afterwards we're gonna look at the
exercises some of them so 20 minutes
right or I don't know when was the or
did you know when was it originally
supposed to start
[Applause]